Hello, everyone.
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa, sorry.
Hello.
Hello, everyone.
Sorry, sorry.
That we were a little late.
But yes, for those who weren't reading chat and why I had to start late, I was I was had to emergency sub for a friend for rivals, charity tournament which is very poorly organized it was so fucking bad I was just I was supposed I was checking it out um and um and they literally were in the drafting phase for players and apparently half the players didn't even show up for the tournament and I was just like what like I was just listening and then they were apparently they got too many DPS slash tank players and not even enough support players and i was so fucking confused and then i was watching them argue for 30 minutes trying to beg players to sub in um for as like a support player it was so bad and i learned about this turn i heard about this turn that they've been planning on doing because they did an eu separate uh they did an eu version of this like last week and then um and then uh so then version because i was like uh my friend was telling me about the tournament that i was
helping organize like that was helping as a player by the way he wasn't even uh like super gomez was telling me about this tournament and he was helping the organizer as a player to do like for uh as a player because he wanted to help out for charity so um so i was like oh okay like are you do you get anything out of it he's like no it's for charity i want to help and i want to help organize this for n a and i was like oh that's pretty cool and uh and then like uh they were wanted to do it um literally right after the eu tournament but they had only five players recruited and i literally told them i was like bro you gotta convince the organizer to delay it to next week because there is no way you're gonna find 40 plus players in two days because like because like it's telling me about it and i was like there's no way you're gonna find 40 plus players in two fucking days like you gotta tell them to delay it to next week because that's fucking stupid and so they delayed it to like this
week and yeah and then like um apparently some of the organizers they found players but then like they didn't like fully confirm whether or not they were gonna show up so they just be like the the players would be like yeah i can do it but then they weren't even told the day of the tournament or the time of the tournament so it was like i felt so bad so for those who don't know this was it was under team captain's name but he had like i think like five percent involvement in this tournament from what i'm told and it was like outsourced to like a organizer team i thought it was mostly like eu organizers um but apparently there was like any people helping out as well but it was it was so fucking weird um so then i was watching and then i told him i told uh super gomez that i am willing to be an emergency sub because i felt so bad and also like super gomez has been like super like clutch um whenever like i wanted to like I want to play rivals and I needed to like you know um he was awake
during like my degenerate hours and everything um and you know he played super long hours too and I felt really bad because I found out um later on that like um he had like wrist uh pain and stuff we're doing these long hours so like you know like he never complained about it to me too and um I wanted first off it was for uh charity it was for charity and I thought it was like you know um I'll do it for charity I'm not getting anything out of it and you know I felt so bad because I was listening to them argue for 20 fucking minutes straight uh I was literally listening for 20 minutes straight about them begging players trying to find a support player and everything so like I felt like Jesus Christ fine I'll I can I can emergency cell for this um and then um like and I wouldn't you me and shit like i just wanted to be a good friend uh because like uh he's been like super clutch for me like you know playing rivals uh organizing like rival stacks for me and stuff like that so i just
figured like you know like and he did the vtuber rivals thing too like during the vtuber rivals he coached half our roster out of his own free time and also did like um and also like did vaude reviews and stuff for our team during vtuber rivals like he didn't have to do that Sentinels too and like scrimming and stuff.
And like doing scrims and stuff with us and like and also like researching the enemy team as well like during VTuber arrival.
Like he did all that shit.
So I was like, you know what?
That'd be, you know I wanted to like return the favor and you know, they just needed one player.
Like well they needed a lot of players.
So I was just like, I mean that's fine.
Like I can do it.
And but I like left because like i think that was literally one game because there's no there's no like loser brackets so
there was no so like we lost the game so i guess they're out now so i was like okay
i was just like okay i guess they're out now i guess i can stream escape from duck cop i don't no, I don't know any of these rules.
It was, um, I don't know any of these rules.
So I literally, like, I'm just looking at, I was a bystander.
And then there were supposed to be like, okay, teams are supposed to be balanced.
And then it's supposed to be a snake draft.
And because half the roster, half the players didn't show up for this tournament, um, or like dropped out at the last second because like apparently one of the players on super gomez's team um that i replaced um he didn't want to play with pizza this other player on that team so he was like i'm out like he saw which team he got drafted on and he was like i'm fucking out i'm not playing with this guy i'm like what the fuck crazy right so like some people are like oh yeah i'm fucking i'm like they literally dropped out at the last second it's wild like for charity by the way yeah it's understandable if you see the play okay you can drop like it's understandable if you have like conflict with someone in a tournament because i saw the player list and i was like oh i don't want to i hope i don't want to be on this uh team on this person because he's like apparently like known as being like super sexist or whatever um like in the rivals community and has like done like pretty uh has like
done some pretty like fucked up shit um but you know and then so I was like when I saw the playlist I was like yeah I don't want to be on a team with that guy like if I joined this because I was asked if I wanted to I was just like but like you know if you see the playlist and you don't fuck with someone then just don't join the tournament it's just that easy like it's literally yes you'd be like oh just suck up just suck up and participate but like you know if you do have someone that you really don't want to play with just don't join the tournament because you don't know if you're gonna fucking get drafted on that team like you don't fucking know like and then um yeah and then uh because it's all r and g and shit like if i see i i do that i they give me i'd be like can i can i um can you tell me like who's gonna be like i'll be like oh can you tell me like who's gonna be part of this event or who's gonna be part of this like or like tournament and i see the list and i'll be like oh i
don't know i feel a little awkward maybe no it's all right i'll pass on that like shit like that like i've done that before it's so easy just say just say no
and then um and then yeah Yeah, and it was and then like because half the play almost half the players didn't show up for this tournament It was so it like some teams were just grabbing random pros that said yes or like like top 100 players So like you know instead of like the players they drafted in the snake draft They're like literally like you top 100 player.
You're on my can you stop in fab And then obviously my team got the short and the sick players and i'm not a professional by the way uh haven't played much of this season rank by the way like and also my other support player also hasn't really played much this season or much rivals at all like we were like yeah we can't help but hold me up and then we were up against like a full fucking professional team because that team also had half the roster not show up but they were managed to grab like professional players or like uh top 100 players it was i it was a little bit of a mess i just i just don't understand how this was so poorly organized i because it's such a bad look too um it's such i feel like if you know that this to be super organized you'd you know delay it you'd you know delay it don't keep going yeah like don't don't do this thing because it's like it's such a poor like yeah it it just looks bad you know and i just feel bad because like obviously it's like it's trying to do
like a good thing to raise money for a good cause and everything this is why i you might have seen me not organize events this year it's because i've been so busy and i don't want to half-ass an event like i try to make sure everything is um everything is like okay and stuff so um i gotta make sure like everything is can will go okay and i don't want like any like um unpredictable variables and everything have everybody confirmed and stuff and make sure everyone can show up and even if they can't show up i have backups ready for it um so you can see i just don't have time i haven't had much time lately to organize anything this year because i've been so fucking busy with everything else that's going on um and you guys know like this year i had to like um a lot of shit have this year too and i've been traveling a lot as well and it's very stressful it's a very stressful thing and i usually don't even have a team when i'm organizing i i didn't even have a team when i organized my um my
like wrestle tuber or um or like the apex event it was just mostly me gathering everything and like talking to people and everything um so i just can't believe i was like you had a team you had yeah and the birthday concert I organized that all by myself so I'm just like bro you had a team like how did that happen like yeah so I was just like how do I have didn't show up and everything and like obviously vibes were fucking off and everything because like you know people were just so frustrated um with how it was handled i feel really bad i felt really bad for like you know a lot of these players i felt really bad for super gomez because like he helped he helped like he did it out of his own free time for charity um and he wasn't even credited
of it i think there was i don't know i thought they made like a liquipedia or whatever and they didn't even credit him even though like he literally had to recruit like he was like begging players to like join the tournament and not begging i won't say that's the word he was like you know asking players and messaging a ton of players um and then i was watching the stream too because like you know he even asked me and i was like i don't know like i saw the raw player list and i was like I don't know.
And I was like, it's for charity.
And I was just like, I'll think about it.
And then like, because I could tell it was like, Trudeau not very well organized in general.
So that's why I was like hesitant in joining it.
But I literally did it.
I joined it last minute, just because like I did it as a homie.
Um, because, um, I, I just felt so bad, like watching all of this unfold.
And, and like, even it's like, no, you don't have to come.
You don't have to come.
Like, focus on your stream like i feel like i feel really bad but i was like literally watching the show unfold and like i felt bad for like everyone i i just i just felt so bad for everyone involved uh so i was just like i it's that's fine like that's okay like yeah i'm looking at the the liquidpedia right now and like he's not even credited even though like and then he had to do the drafting he he was organized i was watching the stream and he was organizing the drafting himself even though he was like this isn't my job but i guess i have to do the snake draft as well i was like bro i was just like bro i like yeah and i'm looking at it and the entire producer like an eu like the team's all an eu like on for an egg tournament like are you even half of them awake for this like are even half of them awake right now like oh wait a moment bro it just sucks like it is for charity yeah at least like credit because I saw how hard like they've been like working I saw how hard like they were
trying because they were trying to like get anyone and you know they even asked me if I could like ask some people too um yeah anyway other than that did you guys see the stock market sorry the CS goes sorry not CS the CS stock market crash today I want to talk about this I know you guys all want me to play duck off but This is very important,
but we had the biggest bubble burst of our entire lives.
I had two people message me about this.
And I was like, I was like, bro, I don't even play.
I don't, first off, I don't even like do CS.
Second off, it was such a big news that I had two people message me about.
It was literally a sell, sell, sell, sell.
Oh, wait, I bookmarked this tweet.
so bad okay for those who don't know valve updated a new did a new pattern it's like it's a small update that literally destroyed like the the the stock the cs economy um so now for those who don't know the only way to get knives and gloves is you can have to open them in cases and buy like buy it but now you can trade up now so you can literally get shitty items and start trading up um and everything so you can trade like you and then apparently um the tier below knives and gloves are is reds and people were biting really we're buying really really shitty reds um um and trading them up so to get knives and gloves so it crashed the entire stock market because you can keep trading up so you can go from blues to like whatever the fucking colors are and then
it was really bad because value dropped by like more than 60 percent of all knives like of everything except for the shitty reds yeah the one update wiped out one billion oh two billion dollars of value in like in in cs trading because cs trading is like crazy like
markets mark make their own disasters I I ends they give us super chat thank you thank you yes so okay I love this quote this is so people were like and because apparently there's some websites where you could instantly sell your stuff without having it affected by this so people were like sell sell sell like Like,
because some people, you know, some people didn't wake up in time to read the update.
So those who were awake for the update and realized what was going on instantly sold all their inventory before the crash happened.
Like before the people started waking up and realized about the crash.
Because they updated it.
Because, like, apparently, majority of the market is in EU and Asia.
But they posted the update in NA time.
so people were buying up all the cheap ass reds um before like the eu and asia bros woke up and selling all the shitty stuff before they woke up
so yeah yeah so like people were like make we're like we gotta get it all get rid of everything get rid of it all and like I saw this fuck that freak the fuck out and panic sell everything right now it's fucking over
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so so so I saw it I was like holy shit the very real quote yeah yeah
so anyway so the entire economy collapsed now in um um in the the sea the yeah the the cs the cs economy and i saw this video too it was pretty crazy he was like so this is what my inventory was like before wait wait let me i'll put the so listen to this 58k dollars okay yeah now we make a shake let's see guys 58k to what 58k
by the way it went from 58k to 18k so like i could i can't be bothered to show the video but i gave you
market crash of 1929 modernized so 58k one day within 24 hours he had his his mod item value was 18k in 24 hours now imagine what the value will be in another day like the pain was so audible like the cost was just god i had to talk about it was i was like reading up on it and and i was like because like i was i was like there at i was there at like uh what's the word called at point like when it happened wait there's a there's a word for it guys what's the word called like when you're there while it was happening like when it first started half ground zero yes I instantly I checked the CS trading what the CS the CS trading Reddit I had to know I I had to know what was going on there were there were some very interesting I went there I had to know I had to know like how did these people feel
it was it was a i saw some wait let me second um because i was linking it to some of my the two of my friends who were i guess like really sad you know i thought maybe you know they can laugh they can laugh through their pain so these funny um these funny posts i know it's on reddit but like pretty funny um as an outsider looking in so i i linked this one um i linked i look i i thought it as an outsider i thought i was really funny i oh yeah um apparently a chinese skin trader lost about 900 000 today that's insane
yeah no the like it just and also it like came out of nowhere like nobody it was like a small update that's literally how it went they're like a small we have a small update today uh that's very small update literally destroyed the entire economy That pros didn't mean.
They didn't even mention it in the update title.
So what this very small update is.
Alright.
Escape from Dupkhov.
It's basically Tarkov.
But better.
How might you ask it's better?
Well it's...
I will say...
They removed multiplayer, which is already an immense improvement from Tarkov.
It's, it's, they removed multiplayer from Tarkov, which already makes it so much better.
And, um, and we're, we're ducks.
We're basically ducks.
Like, holy shit, it's now playable.
Now we're talking game saved online is no more.
Yes, so, so, there's no multiplayer and your ducks, but it's basically Tarkov.
But without any of the bad side of Tarkov, they got rid of 100% of the toxicity.
Yeah, apparently the gun set is every, like, it's literally everything's the same.
It's just your duck.
Someone made a multiplayer.
Never mind.
They're like, this is too much of a good thing.
Zomber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, wait.
I gotta put this here.
There's a research paper waiting to be written.
Yeah, we just can't have nice things.
People were like, how dare you ruin?
This game is too perfect.
Let me pat back multiplayer.
Let's see.
All right.
This sound got alive.
Bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum.
Okay.
General settings.
Borderless full screen.
There we go.
Got to make sure everything.
You know, Duck Anatomy is pretty horrifying.
I agree.
All right.
Let's give me that.
Bum, bum, bum.
All right.
FPS limit.
144.
Bum, bum, bum.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Okay, music down.
I might could turn this down overall.
All right, let me know if everything's good.
All right.
Let's see.
Can I actually add in mods?
Oh, I guess I have to go to, like, the workshop.
All right, let's try it out.
I heard it's...
The game is doing really, really well, right?
Like, there's so...
It's really popular in Asia.
because Tarkov is very popular.
Like every wipe, it's very, like Tarkov is like very, very popular in Asia in general.
So it is doing very well, right?
Like they had like a million player base for a single, yeah, a million copies sold for a single player game of a multiplayer idea.
Like not 100%, but still very challenging.
All right, here you go.
Yeah, it's created by devs.
at Billy Billy
between the two which is what's better Tarkov or cod I have not played Tarkov because oh wait it's shaped like an egg I'm not that's not sorry that was not related to your super chat but when they give us super chat thank you um but uh I've never played Tarkov because I've heard how tilting Tarkov is and it also because it's an extraction shooter it's a single player extraction shooter which is a very unique concept in my opinion because you usually when you hear extraction shooter it's multiplayer so the fact that it is a single player extraction shooter and it has sold a million copies says a lot about this like how good this game is supposedly oh my god do i have a pet look what happened to my face oh wait i'm just i'm just what happened to my face wait what the fuck what what happened hello this is your oh okay you still remember what you look like come over here okay thank god i was gonna be like what happened that's no be am i truly a duck if i don't even have a beak oh i can
create a dragoon technically okay let's create wait wait
no it has to wait a minute uh wait a minute
okay oh wait what happened to the legs
yes lion there just oh my god i can't wear okay we're gonna wear um some kicks oh my god are these toes oh my god wait actually that's much better do i have like customization for the bottom part of the body which is also very important to to my vision uh you want i want to thin this out a little bit
and seven thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right Oh my wait.
Okay, yeah.
Wait, okay.
Three.
I like three.
Oh my god.
Three or...
Okay, three.
Three is good.
Five, six.
Okay, we're gonna be here for a while.
Actually.
How far is that?
Oh.
Actually.
the customization for this is pretty not gonna lie wait the customization for this is pretty good all right
oh but what if okay wait this is gonna be hard there's so many there's so many endless possibilities all right there we go and then tip okay we got the eyes what's the crest oh it's like the hair all right let's see it what can we do for the hair oh no none of these actually speed up speak up dragon i mean we could do this and make it like a horn yeah i think so we can do that okay beak type
okay wait oh there's so there's so many it's so hard to decide what the fuck is that
okay we need this we need that i
don't know it's so hard to decide which one i want to do
um i think you've got five gifted ships thank you thank you i mean this is basically me Oh my god, it's like the Amazon check
Wait, I'll put it here
Wait, actually, now that I
Wait, wait, can I Oh, are you serious?
I wanted to make a little frowny's face No fun No fun, I was gonna do a little frowny face
Okay You don't have frown
All right, we'll do this.
There you go I don't know guys.
It's so hard.
Okay, we'll do this All right
I mean the wings oh wait there's wing types.
Oh my god, I can just give you hands like you're not even a bird anymore You're just just a regular you're just a regular person all right we'll we'll we'll start with wings we'll do wings just just so like it won't be weird all right and then tell color will be this there you go there's the dragon tail and then it's me yellow duck wait i'm scared
no no
Did I click it?
No!
It was perfect!
Oh my god, it goes so tall.
It was...
What was it?
I don't remember.
What did I do?
I...
Guys!
Okay, wait.
I think I can redo this.
No.
help I can I can fix this I think I can remember it it was crest again oh yeah we were it was like this oh I know it was that I can fix this everything is fixable okay and then this was white I remember and then um the beak was this yeah it was this and then there we go And then bro got tall.
I don't remember how tall it was.
I don't even remember.
We can rebuild him.
We have the technology, guys.
There you go.
Alright.
Was the head smaller?
Can it actually...
Like this?
Okay, it'll be like this.
And then...
the tail okay i remember the tail all right and we can't we can't forget the most important one there we go that good was that was that it i don't remember i was this how wait i think the eyes the eyes were definitely smaller yeah yeah there you go i remember now
There we go.
What the heck?
Alright, you can wake up.
Even the kid was like, The fuck?
Wake up now.
Even the kid was like, What the fuck?
That's you!
It's you!
It's us.
Alright.
Wake up.
You awake yet?
Don't know me yet, but I've been watching you for days, bro.
I'm putting a bold plan into motion and I need a partner.
I think you're perfect for this.
But first, you need to prove yourself.
Your test?
Escape from this place.
Everyone's busy with their morning coffee.
It's your chance to escape.
Don't worry.
I made a few preparations for you.
You'll see.
open move out extraction point is just outside all right wast is moving this is me on i'm a dragoon yes look here all right well oh there it is straight away oh my god there's a cloth i don't know what has to okay f pick up okay all right oh that's nice that it tells me here okay Oh,
wait, I gotta reload.
Fuck!
Can I use the toilet?
Oh, is there anything?
Nice.
FX, energy 10, hydration.
Okay, cool.
Wait, I can eat this?
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Why didn't the game bore me?
How is I supposed to know that I wasn't supposed to eat it?
Om yum yum Equip your weapon before heading out Once equipped, press one or two Press artery load Press space bar To dodge, go for it Oh, that's cool Dodge when you see the red flash Pop, pop, pop, pop There you go, oh my god Oh shit, nice Free food Oh my god I gotta dress up That's right,
I'm you now Wait, can I eat it?
Wait, why is it lift?
shit
oh look at that's just the dead body all right bro you can't do capitalism nine out of ten what's the point if i can't eat their bodies duck aboard oh down a little bit more okay sure uh let me know this is better here's an important tip hold the right mouse button to aim for better accuracy be allowed with the med kits in the crates forward.
Alright.
I don't think I need heal.
Well, to aim for... Oh.
It's like scoping in.
So they actually have the scope mechanic too.
Do I need reload?
No, I don't.
Nice.
Oh, I have two weapons now.
I'm going to reload this.
I know I'm ready to shoot my gun.
Oh!
I don't need that.
Okay, I need that.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god i gotta heal uh bandage wait i gotta put this here and i put my aspirin too all right repairing all right um wait is this like oh okay we don't need that we'll drop that i already have that sunglasses
I'll grab the ammo, so I'll take the ammo.
There you go.
There's no way they can headshot me.
Press shift.
Oh, I can sprint.
Where's my stamina?
Where is my stamina bar?
God, I'm so thirsty, apparently.
Well, I don't even see my stamina bar.
Secret item, if you go all the way back?
What do I get?
Alright, I'll go all the way back.
I'm ready for a secret item.
I like secret stuff.
Okay, reloading.
A green circle?
Oh, I see it now.
I was looking down.
That's why I didn't see it.
Because you know, like, you expect to look down, you know?
I realize it's like right behind you.
Is it more poop?
Give it to me straight.
Where would oh is it like back here all the way?
Oh, because I didn't see this door Oh, it's back here.
It's a carrot Wait, is there even more wrong way turn back now.
I don't know how to read
You said secret item There
I was told that it was a secret item.
And you're like, the carrot is a secret item.
What are you talking about?
There might be.
Oh my god, I gotta loot this all over again.
You fuck it.
Oh my, I have to do a tutorial again.
There we go.
Alright, let's get like a speedrun This I think, oh my god It's RNG too It's not even the same items You could sneak You can get your stuff back Do I really?
Okay, alright Do I really?
Can you actually kill him?
Get the...
How?
Welcome to duck off all right all right we're gonna try this again all right here we go oh my i just realized i forgot give me a sec i just realized my aim but i ain't working so well this is why i died it's because my aim but i was turned off there we go
fixed it all right there you go
Guys, I hear him.
How do I sneak?
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
That's okay.
I'm safe.
I'm safe now.
You're right.
Right, Boris.
Because I don't think I can get my shit back.
Guys, I have a feeling it's gone, gone, gone, run, run far away.
I don't think I'm getting it back, guys.
I think it's over for me.
You gotta fight for it.
I'll come back later.
Here's the other guy.
Come on.
Come on, get out of here.
There we go.
It's fine.
I don't need him.
But the secret item.
I'll come back when I'm stronger.
You cat.
I'll find a way.
There's nothing in here.
I got a heal though.
I had to use all my healing for that one area.
Fight or flight.
Exactly.
Alright, let's go this way.
One way.
It's two way, guys.
I can come back.
I'll come back, guys, I swear to God.
I'll come back.
She never came back.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll be back, guys.
Surely I'll be back right here.
Extracting.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll be there.
There's an extraction, which means there is an insertion later.
That's why I need a P. I'll be right back.
And I'm back.
Oh, so sound guy.
I hope the sound has been okay so far.
Let me know if I have to adjust anything.
You like jazz.
Boom, boom, boom.
So I realized I had to turn this down.
Oh, they even Super Chat Smokey Krish.
What else?
Who else?
I need a alt tab for that.
Smokey Crush, Zechra, Maha, Smug, Hey guys, Never Sleeping Gavs, Matt, JL, Forward, Bite, Medi, and Allen.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I could change my face, but why would I do it?
I'm ready perfect.
Oh, Capuchino, Cadence.
Let's go.
Oh, it's a workbench.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, what's this?
Is this my bed?
Oh, I can pass the time.
Wait, is this my empty house?
Oh, I guess this is where I live.
Hello!
Hey, you're finally awake.
Hey, Jeff.
This is your new year.
Here are a few things I need to explain.
I'll take care of logistics and everything else out here is in your hands.
This is the warehouse.
You can store your items here.
This is the construction panel.
You can build or dismantle facilities from here.
And this is the vending machine.
Not a wide selection of goods, but you can sell unwinded items to it as well.
This is, well, we'll just call it the enhancer.
Find the right materials and enhance your abilities.
Though it might come at a small cost.
This is the bunker exit you'll be heading up from here.
We don't have much of your name right now, so bring back as much as you can.
Before heading out, don't forget, I've got some quests for you.
Oh, sir, give me the quest.
All right, basic constructions.
Collect two pieces of wood.
Okay, I can do that.
You don't survive here.
I'll give you some startup capital.
Wow!
Are you gonna give me some CS skins?
This is before the crash.
This is before I knew about the crash.
Oh, my God.
Let me set up my entire, my entire worth on CS skins.
Oh, never.
Surely the market will never crash because it only goes up.
It's like those who like invested all their money into gold.
Uh...
Bye, bye, bye!
I can't wait to invest in CS skin.
I'll buy...
Yeah, I'll put the 401k into the skins.
Surely it'll always go up.
Do you want, like, a percentage in the stock market or a percentage in CS skins?
Kill any enemy.
Yeah, I can do that.
The gold will rise again, guys.
What's this?
Pick up locker.
Okay, warehouse.
Oh, I got some milk.
Okay, I can put this away, actually.
The...
What?
The milk.
Oh, it's like the glock.
Which is better.
Does it not have, like, a comparison?
I don't know what is better.
Current ammo 10, caliber S.
14, 11.
Oh, I should get the...
gilk then god it sounds like i'm saying a slur like sorry i say i'm gonna get my gilk i feel like i'm saying something bad i don't know it doesn't sound like a good word it sounds disgusting it what it has stuck it just sounds very wrong i don't know up okay um i feel like i'll put the stone here all right let's go hello my oh he's he's my backpack that's what he is yeah yeah i'm gonna get you with my cloak i don't know it just it doesn't sound right all right here we go wait a second if you want to head back you can return to the bunker from here on your further out just find some green smoke that'll bring back to you all right get going now all right here we go let's go i feel very safe i have a ti 13 all right what's this bubble over there i don't even know how to get there all right i'm just gonna go loot real quick i got fiber and bolt how do i get the trees.
I guess I'd have to, like, loot that, right?
They don't see... Oh, wait, there's a duck there.
That's right.
Get shot at!
There you go.
This is my territory.
Give me your cash.
Oh, my God.
He has some cash on him.
That's right.
You in my world, bitch.
Um...
I can put this here.
Yeah, let's put some aspirin here.
I already don't have inventory.
space.
I have a very small backpack.
Wait, what's this?
The data box.
Oh, it's a blueprint.
I got cash.
Oh, yeah.
Paper cash.
I don't know what to do.
I guess I don't need two guns.
I guess.
X.
I already have all the guns I need.
So we'll grab the data.
I got potato graphics card.
Wait, what?
I thought I dropped you.
Drop.
I want that blueprint.
all right we gotta get extracted soon i need to find wood before i head to the extraction because that's important where the fuck is that wood toolbox yeah it's good i can put stuff in the pet slot there's no pet slot it's just back oh here oh i see it i see If I'm wood.
Or is it someone's house?
Oh, I see a say.
Who's there?
Hmm.
I see great potential in you.
How about learning body training from me?
Body training makes you stronger and smarter.
Come.
Master's got your first challenge ready.
Oh my god, Master.
Balanced nutrition.
Submit.
Duck egg.
What?
Oh my god, I am a carn- I am a cannibal.
Your first task.
Bring me a duck egg.
Do squats while searching.
Go.
Remember, discipline sets you free.
Oh shit.
Are we gonna eat a child?
Can't be bothered to sit.
You're right.
Sitting's for losers.
Sitting waste time.
Why sit?
We're not gonna do my squats i know where can i find wood in the forest i don't understand
where could it be uh
actually where is the wood in the goddamn forest do i have a map oh i'm here where's the extraction zone though like i'm gonna find wood oh my god there's a dog there was a dog You don't even have loot.
What's the point of killing you for fun?
Oh, this... Oh my god.
Where's... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I panicked.
I got shot at.
I just never expect them to fight back.
Oh shit.
An ADR?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
This guy was juiced.
All right, now I'm fucking gaming.
Is there wood here?
No, it's just stone.
Okay, now I can keep going.
I'm gonna eat my food, too.
Again, aspirin.
Okay, I should have ate my carrot before I ate my...
Who's shooting?
Oh, that's not my fight.
I am worried about...
That's not my fight.
duh oh he's a traitor oh i can get wood okay but i don't need wood right now i'm gonna steal your shit get more recipe i need that aspirin actually yeah he's a merchant do you have wood here oh that's pretty oh no that's just the logs it will go this way i don't have to money.
I ain't made out of duck gold.
I'm in the duck economy.
I'm just a little duckling.
I'm like a peasant in the duck world.
I got a cup and a clip.
A sip though.
I'm gonna give my dog a fucking lighter.
There we go.
Bye.
I don't know what you were... Whoa!
Where am I?
Oh, it's like a little teleporter aspirin why not oh i don't need that actually i'm still trying to find wood in the forest how is this the hardest thing to find oh wait that's a syringe wait this is all so good fuck okay we don't need the police baton i'll get a water bottle i feel that's much better yeah i'm looking at toolboxes but i haven't seen any wood in the toolboxes green i got so absorbed in fishing that i didn't notice that the storm's rolling in had i had in the cave all day as soon as i went in a purple guy attacked me because i had a gun the cave water had no fish which was a real letdown still from what i observed different weather effects what fish you can catch.
Oh, so I can fish here.
Throw wood.
Oh, my God, wood!
That's actually the one thing we needed.
Okay, what do we not?
What can we throw away?
I don't feel that...
Yeah, we don't need...
We don't need that.
Let's just grab wood.
All right, let's go home.
Let's go home, Dad.
If I can figure out how to get home.
Okay, this portal.
Oh, oh, the TP takes me back home.
That's so convenient.
Oh, that's what this is.
Alright.
Nice.
We're extracting.
I like how my helmet doesn't even cover my eyes.
Stay hydrated.
Extract.
Can't build anything?
No, because I need two fucking wood.
I did kill someone.
Yay, I got my startup capital.
I claim all.
If you have the right gear, you can take on those rampaging scavengers.
The red ones with butcher knives.
Once you're done, I'll leave some bolts and nuts.
Okay, kill rampaging scavenger.
I need a butcher knife.
Okay, that's easy.
All right, let's put some our stuff away.
Okay, we gotta put away the...
We have blueprints.
Wait, can I use the blueprints?
when it's like oh actually i should grab the med kit too all right can i use the blueprint now wait how do i use the blue oh not now oh okay all right let's go dad let's go shoot some more ducks oh i didn't make more stage oh you're right you're right this is why duck cough is so much better than Tarkov.
You can't...
Well, technically you can hack in a single player game, but, like, I don't have to fight hackers.
You're right.
This is why it's so much better.
Do they, like...
Oh, they restock itself!
Oh, I got the... I got the ducking!
Oh, my God.
My coach is gonna be so happy.
I got the ducking, coach.
Let me grab this.
Right here, duck.
I see how someone slew.
nice i don't know what this oh i got flat head screwdriver next storm is that a hunt what does the storm do chat what does that do metal plate butt weapon wood okay we got it we got everything we need where is the coach guys was he yeah i don't know where he lived what oh that scared me I was like,
oh my god, I got a shotgun now, though.
Wait, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Alright.
I got a shotgun.
Is he, too, though, right?
Building right next to me?
Like, right here?
Does he live here?
Wha.
That's right.
Can't get me.
I have a fucking building.
There we go.
Okay.
What did he have?
I don't need a PM.
I don't remember where he lived.
Oh, is it this house?
Oh, he's right next to me.
He lives here.
I got him this egg.
Apple, soda, cracker, cola.
Am I hungry?
Oh, I'm thirsty.
Oh, crowbar.
Wait, let me...
I should have drink my soda right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I saw that I was, like, super thirsty.
All right, let's go.
Let's go give him the egg.
Hey, bro.
I got you the egg.
Got you your goddamn protein, bro.
There's one.
Oh, I got, I just got that.
So protein alone just isn't enough.
Carbs are important, too.
Go, fetch me a cookie.
Run.
It's okay.
I literally just picked it up.
Yay.
I'm level two.
All right, what does he want?
He wants a cigarette.
Yeah, that's all.
Take care of the guys.
Bro, I think, bro, I don't think the cigarette's going to solve anything, bro.
Still feels like something's missing.
As they say, smoking after a meal.
Bring me a pack of smokes.
This is your final trial.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, there's all this...
Oh, wait.
Look, he has his egg again.
Well, goink, my...
A breakfast of champions.
Bro, I don't know, bro.
I don't think...
I don't think a toilet cleaner.
A pack of smokes might as healthy for you.
He needs a mental...
I'm just going to go back home.
I need, like, more inventory space, though.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to, like, make him put away, like, the lighter feel that I got.
Oh, this way.
I go home.
What happens after dark?
I thought fun things happened after dark.
Don't push yourself too high.
Don't worry, I'm coming home.
You can get more...
Oh, there is a skill tree.
Am I too weak to access the skill tree right now?
I can, oh, I can buy it, but, okay, nice.
It becomes more dangerous.
Oh, okay, that's what happens.
I was like, what happens at night?
Surely good things always happen at night, right?
Like, oh, I have enough.
Okay, there we go.
I needed more of that, actually.
That's nice.
Oh, my God, I can buy a B-Ball!
Oh, I can't buy a B-Ball on port.
Never mind.
I was so excited.
I was going to be like, I can buy a B-B-B.
All right.
Let's throw this away.
All right, let's...
Yeah, but I have double...
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
My inventory did not expand.
It seems like my inventory stayed the same.
Wait.
Oh.
What happened?
What did it do?
Did it not?
Did it not give me more items?
Oh.
It was cosmetic.
I just see pouch but forgot the most important word cosmetic I didn't notice the cosmetic part how do I sell oh sell okay I just press F um I don't know there's nothing here okay I'm selling this I'm selling it back all right oh a butcher knife I can craft that Nothing I really...
A poop ball, which can be thrown.
I just need a poop.
Okay, I don't think there's anything I really need to buy.
Okay, I got bandage.
What else?
Bleeding control.
Oh, I've used that in that before.
Fix the northern signal tower.
Letters.
Submit letter from an old friend.
Okay, I can do all that.
Is it this?
Is this a skill tree?
Oh!
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, I need to pay for it.
It's pay to learn.
Okay.
Just like college.
But then the learning part is sort of like just a suggestion.
Survival instinct.
Wide FOV.
I feel like I'd rather get done.
But like it's a gotcha wave.
You actually do learn it.
If you do learn anything.
Yeah.
Okay, I don't have anything else.
That's got more backpack.
What is over here?
The farm town.
I mean, is this like the guy from Animal Crossing?
The Kappa from Animal Crossing?
Alright, cold caffeine.
It's so chill.
How much did I sleep?
Is that always still night?
all right how do i that should be morning right there you go 628 the early duck gets the worm all right i'm ready wait i forgot to i need to grab my screwdriver i'm pretty sure right
uh we'll put this away i remember okay there you go i was like i remember i had a screwdriver let's go back we need to how do i look at the quests actually what is the quest oh there it is i'm just an average duck um i would like to say above average my hat doesn't even fit my head i am an above average duck okay i need to get cigarettes use a band-aid flathead screwdriver fix the northern tower signal okay we'll do that we'll find the area for that the northern north is up so where the fuck is that this is it where is that is it this but that's like that's like east so where else could the tower be I'm just It'll go right side.
I'm slightly above average.
Duck.
Let's grab some crackers.
Duck's hungry.
Is this one, right?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I was going to say, where's my bullets?
Oh, fading feather.
Feels like it would disappear soon.
I don't even know what that does.
Rock would.
Reload.
Can I assume it's this.
Oh, there it is.
I'm fixing.
Okay, I finished the objective.
Wait, does he have another blueprint for me?
Oh, he does.
Wait, I can just farm blueprints off this guy.
Nice.
Wait, who shot him?
Wait, who shot this dog?
Because I did not shoot this dog.
Despite what he was doing.
you just saw i swear i swear it wasn't me guys like you saw that right you got shot before i shot him
i can build this all right nice that's right never you never expect a duck from the bridge oh all right i can't run and gun with an ak which i've noticed It's a little annoying.
Oh my god, please.
I was hoping that I will find a bandage while walking around.
Oh my god, this guy has a shotgun.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I'm bleeding.
I'm bleeding.
There we go.
I don't know.
I figured I'd get like a fucking bandage from this.
Versus like me bringing my own bandage.
Oh, go down.
Sure.
Oh, that was extraction point?
I thought it was just the sewers.
Oh, wait.
No, it is just the sewers.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, it's the fading feathers.
Okay, what do I do for this?
Can I offer it?
How do I offer it?
What?
oh do i have to find eight oh i fucking just like put it there now like stockpile it now i see i see i need circuit board cd drive and metal plate is that it what are stuff do i need okay all right let me uh signal tower claim build a weapon shop upgrade workbench all right Let me put my stuff away then.
Oh, I don't have any bullets left.
Oh, we'll just put this in here.
Oh.
Wait, actually, sort.
Do we need shotgun bullet?
And I'm not just...
What did I put down here?
That...
Oh.
Yeah, I need more bullets.
Oh my god, I need this.
Um, oh, this one.
The T-O-TOS-66-45.
Wait.
Oh, I already have that.
JK.
I might get to sell it.
Actually, let me sell it.
Where is it?
I've doubles, so I might as well sell it.
Sell that.
Yeah, sell my doubles.
I feel like I don't need doubles.
all right up i go why won't he accept my whiskey why whiskey is just like cigarettes like pick your poison all right actually since i don't have bullets i'll just put that here i swap my gun i don't know if i should use a shotgun oh yeah what do i have to what quest i have to do cigarettes bandage oh my god i still forgot to bro fucking forgot to bring the bandages again all right it's fine i'll just keep exploring i was like this time i'll remember to bring bandages she didn't remember right am i thirsty no jesus you got bandages a k 7 for you based on the oh money I don't know if I like the AK.
I'm just going to do regular gun.
I think the AK is pretty garbage.
I'm not AK.
Sorry.
I think the shotgun was pretty garbage.
But also because I maybe...
Maybe it's just because I was a bit too far away.
Do I have enough bullets for an AK?
Which one uses that?
Yeah, rusty bullets.
Oh.
No, I don't.
I only have small bullets.
Yeah, the shotgun seems really bad.
I almost shot him.
Well, you want yourself.
You don't need this, right, Trader?
Oh, there you go.
Letters from an old friend.
Surringe.
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
I actually needed this.
Alright.
I used the wrong one.
Oh, shit.
Dude, not the whiskey!
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm feeling good now.
I'm not thirsty anymore.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
There's aliens?
Oh!
Oh my god, it's last of us!
Oh,
whoa!
Okay, it's fine.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Nobody told me there's aliens.
Nobody said there were aliens!
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm...
Please!
Oh!
He had a bomb!
We never said there were an alien.
I had stream sniped!
I can't believe it.
I'm naked now.
A bot stream started to me.
Alright, let's grab this real quick.
Oh my god.
My items.
That's fine.
I'm going in naked.
I'm getting my shit back.
I'm naked and afraid.
Oh yeah, I forgot I have a dodge.
Okay, I did not need to dodge anything there.
I just literally got shotgun to the face.
I was already so vulnerable.
See, I told you guys.
I didn't need to grab anything.
I already got a gun.
No one ever expects aliens.
What do I...
Um...
Alright, it's this way.
I got grouped in the PvE.
Why did nobody stop him?
Nice, I grabbed that.
i'll get there like where's my pinpoint thing right click on the map oh there it is it's a little scuff though thing the right click a little scuff there you go i don't have any armor so this is like a little scary um what's this an unusual oh it's like Why can't I use my unused syringe?
I don't understand.
Oh, no.
Yeah, so what happened was that he had a shotgun, and then I was, like, next to him.
So, like, you know, not the smartest thing to do.
Okay, I got the AK back, but I don't know if I have the ammo for it.
I do.
Okay.
Now I just don't really have the healers, too.
Yeah, we can grab another blueprint, at least.
Medicine box.
Oh, thank God.
It removes bleed status and grant immunity to bleed.
All right, we need that.
Do I have less?
Oh, I do have less inventory.
Just because of...
Oh, this is bad.
Feel that.
Now I'll keep everything.
I mean, these items aren't that important.
Okay, let's hope that the mushrooms don't get me.
Okay, it does take stamina.
I don't think the mushrooms are here anymore.
What the fuck?
That mushroom was an RNG spawner?
And then it actually spawns?
Oh my god, there's actual spread.
Oh my god, where the fuck did that guy come from?
Oh, this is bad.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, thank god.
I actually needed the aspirin.
Alright.
Actually, I ate the wrong one, but that's okay.
Oh, thank god.
I need all of this.
And $20?
Merry Christmas.
Okay.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, it's okay, he can't even hide it.
Oh god.
Oh wait, maybe I should...
Oh my god, wait!
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Got more ammo.
I got more ammo.
Where is he?
That's fucking right, bitch.
I'm back.
Oh shit!
Oh no!
Guys, I was in fact not back.
I...
It's okay.
Alright.
Now that I know what I need to...
Oh my god, that scared me.
I was like, they took everything.
How did they take it?
Okay, I have app.
Now I know.
It's okay.
I can grab it all back.
This is it right here, right now.
I know where it is.
All right.
And I have enough bullets for it.
As is this way.
Okay, I don't...
Okay.
Okay, I should stop grabbing stuff.
I don't need any of this.
I need to get back first.
All right.
How do you control recoil in a fucking top-down shooter?
We're just gonna book it.
All right.
We don't need to grab any of this.
We'll just go here.
All right.
Oh, please don't tell me that much.
That's not...
Oh, God.
Oh.
Oh, they're fighting someone else.
Nice.
They don't know.
That's where I died.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Reloading.
Reloading still.
There we go.
Oh my god, he has...
Wait, that's not fair.
He has a bulletproof vest.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
There we go.
Uh, oh my god.
Now I have the bulletproof vest.
We need to put this.
Okay, we don't need that because we already have the cosmetics.
Okay, we might need this.
Uh, actually we don't need that.
Wait, damage 11.
Okay, wait.
I'd rather have the lick.
Aspirin.
Where the fuck is the... Where did I put the med kit?
Oh, I threw it here.
Okay, there you go.
That's where I put the mud kit.
All right, let's get the aspirin in fast.
I don't feel so good.
All right.
All right, now I gotta grab my...
No!
Wait, my other grave disappears?
Why did no one tell me?
How could no one tell me this very important thing?
Okay, there you go.
That's everyone, right?
That lives here?
Now I live here.
Wait, that's better.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
That's a better backpack.
If I do say so myself.
Oh, my God.
I got a better backpack.
All right.
Looting.
Ooh.
Plus 17...
wrap this.
Oh my god.
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas to me.
It's early.
We skipped Halloween.
Okay, we have get extracted here.
I don't feel comfortable holding all this loot.
Okay, there's an extraction point right there.
All right.
They're loading.
Okay, there's nothing Does this dog not give any loot?
Is that poop?
Oh, nice.
We got our poop ball.
I still don't know what it does.
Oh, it can be thrown.
Wait, how do I throw this?
Wait, how do I throw the poop ball?
Wait, is there anyone I can throw it at?
Oh, I hear a quack.
Ah!
That's right.
Get pooped!
There we go.
Holy shit, he did so much damage.
Oh my god, he got cigarettes, too.
We did it!
We're gonna fix mental health!
Are extracting?
My intrusive thoughts almost won there.
Get shadowed.
I saw I saw the barrels and I was this close.
It almost won.
Alright, let's get that.
Armor shop.
How do I build all of this okay weapon shop i haven't found a rampaging scavenger yet weapon shop events power electronics medic station all right do i even have any equipment for this oh my god no okay circuit board oh my god i don't have anything i'm so poor a la keep looting um we'll put all of this away what god am i using uh i don't like i I personally don't like the shotgun,
honestly.
There's a standard shotgun, standard bullet.
Yeah, we got a...
We definitely have to get...
Okay, we'll put one med kid in here.
And then...
Oh, wait.
Fuck.
Where's the cigarettes?
Wait, the cigarettes were important.
Oh, there you go.
I'll put all of this away.
Keep the AK.
Okay.
What does the AK take?
Ammo type not set?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's repairable?
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, shit.
I did not realize these guns required, like, extra.
Like, extra stuff.
I did not realize there's durability.
There's durability?
Okay, get this gun out of here.
here.
We're gonna store this.
Rusty bullet.
You don't even have...
Oh, I do.
Okay.
There we go.
AK-7.
You know.
I didn't realize there was durability I have to repair it?
Alright, let's research health.
That's important.
Get that.
And then we'll get recoil control too.
Wait, I we need another backpack.
Yeah, plus four.
And...
Alright.
oh my god truly is oh never mind we gotta go we gotta sleep it's nappy time i don't go got i can't go past my bedtime all right here you go
all right i can see how this can be addicting for people who like tarcov like knowing that you know you won't get headshot 500 miles away like i can i feel like in tarkov i know a lot of people are like super paranoid in tarkov because you can literally get headshot from like across the map and just suddenly lose everything like yeah that seems really nice now no i've never played tarkov before because of that Because of that.
No, yeah, and there's no long queue time, too.
If I shoot this, oh, I knew it.
I was gonna be...
Oh, shit.
Can't help but, like, reload every time.
Like, it makes sense, you know.
That's... It seems very annoying.
Oh, close.
Ooh, I get a lantern.
Oh, yeah, and the queue time is, like, really bad, too.
Oh.
There you go.
Oh shit Oh shit Wait he's destroying the cover There you go Oh my god wait I didn't see me all the way from there Oh shit Oh shit oh shit Oh shit I'm serpentine Okay I got the cover There you go Oh that was scary That was scary I wasn't paying attention to reloading Okay he has eyes how did he do oh that's a lot of loot wait this guy was juiced he had everything oh my god and he has canned beans he was living the life plus one armor plus 1.5 okay we don't need to hear anything why do we need to hear anything when we have eyes loot i'm just gonna grab all the guns so instead of repairing it i can just Replace it with another gun.
Holy shit, there's so much loot.
There's so much loot here.
Uh, oh yeah, I should eat.
I'm a hungry duck right now.
Have any other healers?
I don't think I do.
Alright, let's swap our body armor.
Uh, oh, I do have aspirin.
I'll take some aspirin.
my duck is very thirsty though thirsty for some swans hello you up girl okay nice chocolate vodka bottle water all right i'm very thirsty so clearly i should get vodka
okay nice uh got dumpling and then the rusty shotgun oh it's this here this this this luggage was so juiced last time.
Uh, okay, never mind.
Never mind.
It ain't the same.
How do I get to this side?
Really?
Where are the barrel for that area?
Oh, where am I?
Yeah, I'll go this way.
Look how the aliens show up one time.
Gave me trauma and then never again.
And then they disappeared.
They're like, they knew.
They're like, we sent out a message.
A man of life.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I made a mistake.
Oh no!
I was like, what's that?
Get out of there.
It's so hard.
area of light i couldn't i don't wear stamina my loot
okay bro was maxed out he was maxed out in melee so yeah i don't need i don't need my loot yet i got my gun right here i should i do i got a gun right here okay how where did i die okay okay i gotta figure out how to get there oh like i think part.
I had to figure out how to get back there.
I had so much.
It was like this way and then left side.
Oh my god, right.
Oh my god, you're right.
I had the cigarettes.
I told him I help him with his mental health.
I promised him.
Oh my god.
Oh I'm fucked.
Oh Oh my god, and I'm bleeding No!
Nice thing, I had the best backpack too
Now he's gonna be depressed
Oh my god It's all downhill, I can't pick up loot oh my god it's over it's over i was so kidding too it's so over i had everything i was on top of the world i need a storage fence oh the mighty fall i have to wait for it fuck this i guess i wait for the next wipe.
It doesn't even matter.
I need to go back to that big area.
That's where I got the good shit.
But I don't have good shit to go to the big area.
Three out of rubber, where I could carry 27 items.
Those were the good.
Oh my god.
And then there's a dog.
And I'm also bleeding.
Oh my god.
I guess I'll die.
watch
I'll just die closer don't worry I'll die closer to the oh it's all go don't worry I'll die next to the extraction point there's nothing else I could do oh never mind I just stopped bleeding okay that's it what the fuck is the carrot gonna do it's just gonna give me any hydration and oh wait I should Actually,
I need that.
I say hi, hydrated.
Where the fuck did the dog even come from?
It's all downhill.
Now I know why people rage quit, Tarka.
Now I know.
Now I understand.
Everything is so clear to me now.
Yeah, I gotta take the aspirin.
yum oh my god and the band-aid too i guess i'm just gonna use it up it would suck if i start bleeding again but that's life i swear to god the mushrooms show up again i swear to god i cannot deal with the mushrooms right now all right i have a plan where are they Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
That was my entire plan!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh god.
I'm rolling.
Oh my god.
It was just a goddamn shotgun.
Okay.
We have... Reloading!
Me too!
Oh!
I have this.
There we go.
We got it.
Okay, things are looking a little better.
Things are looking just a little bit better now.
I got a hat and a backpack.
Alright.
And I have two bullets and a dream.
Okay, now I have one bullet and a dream.
Oh my god.
I literally only have shotgun.
okay where is he wait he's going all the way around wait where is he oh my god we're both going in a circle okay we don't know where the other duck is there we go that was close that was so close i got a med kit i'm gonna i'm stimming
geez oh i had so many feathers too i just remembered oh
god okay okay um wait how do i i want to get rid of oh there he is i want to get rid of the stock and put it on okay i guess i can't put it on that all right
okay that's fine we'll grab
okay i think i might i had no okay i missed my good backpack i could carry so much shit those were the good old remember the time when i had when i had 30 plus inventory slots i remember
i remember oh my god a stupid dog holy shit that's gonna is strong he had an egg on him oh it's over here hello knock knock knock i'm very friendly oh my god there you go we have the we have the cigarettes uh also i'm gonna eat a duck egg real fast it's Alright.
Does anyone live here?
Oh, I need a key.
Okay.
Food box.
Oh, we're gonna save his mental health, guys.
We're gonna do- we're gonna be heroes!
I know there was a duck here.
There he is.
Get your ass out of here.
I don't think he sees me.
Bye.
Oh, shit!
He saw me!
oh my god it's okay i can't extract here oh my god it's right next to me don't worry he's gonna miss right is it it would be a shame if you shot those two barrels all right we gotta go straight to the muscle man to get him his cigarettes let's put some stuff away um we got the helmet
um i'm putting all of this away and then get rid of that
actually we need the med kit
uh there you go this is fine all right we go go we go again oh wait does my warehouse have a travel bag does it
wait do i
oh shit i do oh my god i'm saved do i have anything good to craft oh my god just fucking keep crafting poop balls all right let's go i gotta reload okay i have like one i only have one mag
i have one mag on my ak which is not like idea oh that's like I thought, like, I was just lucky that I kept spawning a gun, but it's just, like, mandatory spawns.
I was like, wow, I'm so lucky.
It just keeps spawning a gun.
Oh, shit!
It just keeps spawning a gun for me.
It's fine.
A little bit of bleeding won't hurt anybody.
What the fuck?
There you go.
I didn't learn to tap that.
Not the duck, but, like, the gun.
It's gotta clarify.
I don't mean tapping the duck.
I just meant the gun.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Alright.
Let's go give him his cigarettes.
Hello.
I am here to solve mental health.
Don't worry, buddy.
I got what you need
Alright, nice Is that it?
Build a proper gym for mud I have to build you a fucking gym?
I've decided I'm getting a roommate They were very good roommates I'm moving in with you We'll even pay rent Build a gym at your place And okay, and are you going to contribute to the Bro, we can just move your gym You already have everything in the gym.
Why don't the build?
Bro, you already have everything you need.
Like we can just move your shit over.
Like, give you a... Why don't the fucking spend more money?
Valid crash out, but he is useful.
Then watch out, I just bring his shit.
I have eight bullets left
Like why I spend my own hard-earned money My own quack dollars Into like building him a new gym Wait oh my god it's a man of light Okay wait I think I can live Okay I'm ready Wait I have eight bullets Oh wait I have this Oh shit okay Wait Guys guys why did that one stop me
Oh my god, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Oh my god!
Do I need to do one?
I didn't have enough.
I didn't have enough stamina.
Bro, I didn't have enough.
There's nothing I can do.
I had no more stamina.
Okay, wait, wait.
I got this.
Wait, I think I can take him down.
I have a plan.
Guys, I have a plan.
Okay, wait, we gotta grab this, though.
Watch this.
I'll reload.
He can sprint and reload.
Oh, I should have done that.
Why didn't I do that, guys?
I thought I looked so cool though But I did look cool Until I ran out of stamina I did look pretty cool Until I ran out Okay this is it So don't have a lot of bullets though Which is sort of The worst part of this plan Okay we're gonna We're gonna put the shot Shotgun.
Okay, I have shotgun for him this time.
This time, we got this.
Okay.
I think I can kill that man of light.
I think it's possible.
Wait,
he's...
Guys, it's not pot...
Okay.
Guys, it was it was not possible It was it was it was not possible guys guys there was no way I could get a barrel shot with what he was fucking doing guys
I could I got look when he was running at me I had so much fear like it was just he had just so much And I had none.
I could.
Okay.
I think I could do it.
I understand now.
I figured it out.
Oh, wait.
There's a duck here.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him first before I figure it out.
He had all the confidence in the world.
And I'm just a duck.
Okay.
This time.
I figured it out.
I think I can do it this time.
Okay.
This is it.
This is the game changer.
Right here.
I'm running out of inventory space.
Picking up my own dead bodies' equipment.
That's shotgun.
Okay, this is it.
Right here.
Right now.
This is it.
It doesn't help that he's so fucking fast.
Wait, he's gone.
He was like, I'm done.
That was fun.
I'm heading home.
Like...
It's just like...
That was a fun little game that we had.
He got bored.
He went home.
There we go.
All right, I got more feathers.
Oh, shit.
All right, nice.
Got more shotgun.
Okay, nice.
Do I have any more inventory?
Oh, I do.
I like three more slots, but I have to go home.
Alright, let's head home.
I don't trust myself.
It's almost nighttime, and I'm too scared to find out what nighttime brings me.
Alright.
I'm actually too scared.
Nighttime seems very, very, very dangerous.
Wait, what's in here?
Hammer, nail.
Okay, I don't have that.
All right, uh, we gotta go this way.
I wish I was fast travel.
I wish I could have, like, a motorcycle.
My little toes hurt.
I have to run so much.
My little feetsies.
I'm not even wearing shoes.
all right uh yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hey joki watching your stream in a duck house with my duck friends i hope no one steals all my life savings shoot me with the duck gun hope that doesn't happen to anyone hey let's get this out i want to i want to use the a k whoops i'll put all this stuff away first i wish i was an easier way to store all and so I'm at quick click store all but god I wish there was an easier we already used up my entire inventory oh wait that's bad okay I need to like uh sell my guns
um I need to grab an ak too all right there you go an ak I don't have any bullets for it but like it's oh my god wait I have a dynamo oh god I have zero bullets uh okay We gotta sell our guns.
I didn't realize I have, like, maximum inventory shit.
Sell that.
Where are the guns?
Oh, there they are.
Is it not sorted?
Oh, my God, I gotta sort my shit.
There we go.
I can't upgrade my storage.
Is it for later?
Okay.
Uh...
Get rid of all this.
Let's see...
Oh yeah, way too many of that.
Get this out.
Uh, get you out.
Alright, there you go.
Uh...
I mean, I could craft bullets.
Or...
I hoard my equipment.
And I want to do a quick reload.
The TT are not great weapon.
Okay, I'll get rid of that.
I'll sell it.
Or is it called this one?
Oh yeah, I have a lot of this.
I don't even know why I have that much.
I can't craft anything.
I'm broke.
I don't have a light bulb.
I don't have an MD40.
Oh my god, what do you need a goddamn tire?
There's like 20 cars.
You fucking bring it.
It's bring your own.
Bring your own build.
All right.
Let's go.
I give you the metal sheets.
You bring me a tire.
It's like a potluck.
Like there's cars everywhere.
Why do I have to fucking find a tire?
I think like outside his house is a car.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I need like 8k ammo so badly.
I will go this way.
Hello?
Kablui.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, thank god.
Is that?
Nope.
Yeah, this has to be ammo for...
Oh my god, 175?
Bro, I'm fucking rich.
That's a lot of bullets.
Am I hungry?
Yeah, I am.
Go eat my carrot.
That's a lot of food.
I will go this way.
I'm no longer broke.
Oh, it's because I use this pistol ammo.
I was going to say, like, that's so many, so much ammo.
I didn't realize I was using pistol ammo.
One day...
These crafting materials will be important.
One day.
Grab this.
Alright.
I'll go here.
See, where the fuck did the aliens go?
They disappeared.
They fucking shot me and then like...
They're like, see ya.
Peace.
They sent a message and never returned.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Oh, shit!
There you go.
Oh, they spawned in another rain.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I was going to say, where the fuck did they come from?
There's peace down.
The shoot, yeah, they abducted me and they were like, that's enough for today.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh, that was a tree.
Okay, I was going to say what the fuck
okay only that's what i need for crafting apparently by reloading oh he has a bow okay that bow was like surprisingly so strong last time
okay right oh i think i just used up all my inventory uh is there anything i need here i'm just gonna throw this away Oh, I'll drop this.
Because I want to loot this.
Anything important here?
Okay, carrot, feather.
Okay, more bullets.
Shotgun.
Quick, sorry, I'm fucking getting that.
Alright, let's go extract.
I'm next to extraction point.
Oh, wait, what?
Special bullet?
I don't need carrots.
I'll drop that.
I'll grab the special bullet.
It looks special.
Alright, let's head home.
I'm ready to get extracted.
Stupid.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No!
I want to see him shoot himself.
I was just standing next to the barrel.
Alright.
Oh.
I keep thinking about it
Alright I'm back It's definitely a slow grind I feel like I'm taking It's taking me like a very long time I don't know if it's just because the way I'm playing it Maybe it's just the way I'm playing it That makes it Unless I feel like Tarkov is very grindy Right?
It's very grindy in general
Average extraction shooter okay so it's both okay i was just like wondering am i is it like am i playing it wrong or is it supposed to be like a bit slow yeah
i don't know where to grab loot too that's true they'll sell that maybe that's why i don't know where all the loot shit is
let's see yeah i'll grab the better weapon and then um i need to put i need to need to sell some stuff.
God, I have so much like...
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I definitely need more inventory space.
Okay, I should not be holding poop.
I don't know why I have it.
Here goes that.
okay
okay that's fine i do not have storage space now which is pretty bad i need level four oh i did not level four what am i missing i don't know where to live for some of this like i need to find a light bulb where the fuck is a light bulb i'm gonna buy a light bulb Sarah,
do you have a light bulb I can just buy?
I can't even buy a light bulb.
Bro, what the fuck?
I gotta keep exploring.
Wait, there was one?
Alright.
Fastest mission of my life.
I did it!
I got it!
Finished my mission.
Alright.
Where is it?
oh there's a light bulb yeah i'm gonna finally build something there you go oh my god i recorded hello dragon welcome welcome to my crib wearing a helmet let's even tell me oh plus two armor plus one hearing school bag oh nice so if i do lose anything i just get that.
Okay, uh...
I need...
Weapon Shop.
I need MD40.
Do I have any of this?
Does any of that exist in my trade?
Marker, pumpkin, mechanical key.
Oh, MD40.
Okay, nice.
We actually needed that.
It's a 1.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Uh, we don't want to build this.
Build it here.
What do you have for me?
Okay, nice.
Okay, so, uh, I have ammo and shit.
Oh, I have smoke grenades.
What the fuck?
I still need to find a tire.
I don't know where a tire is.
That's good.
I need the ammo anyway.
The fun sway is ruined now.
Guys, I think I have more important things to worry about.
Okay, I think I can kill him.
I think I can kill the man of light.
I think I'm ready, guys.
This is it.
This was my training arc.
I'm so ready.
This is what I've been training for my entire life.
I can do it.
I bet he's back there.
He's, like, ready for the play date.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Okay, first off, I have to deal with these guys first.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, there's more?
Okay, give me a sec, bro.
Chill.
Like, why can't I just take the time from this car?
Alright, what do I have?
Okay.
Let's grab our guns for money.
Oh, nice.
Cigarettes for my mental health.
Okay, I bet.
You must be back there, right?
Really, right?
Let me use my med kit real fast.
I knew it.
Guys.
Oh!
I told you!
Could be that battle axe!
Oh, shit.
Wait, I got smoke.
Alright.
I'm ready.
There we go.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I downloaded it.
I'm ready.
I got the ultimate weapon.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
I don't have to reload this, too.
Upcoming in.
Boom.
God.
Man of light.
More like man of death.
Brought an actual gunfight.
Boom!
I got that.
I am the new man.
I am the new world's man.
Get over here.
I got something special to show you.
Boom!
There you go.
What do we have?
There we go.
Now I'm definitely playing Dark Souls.
I'm dumping.
I got this.
Holy shit guys, I don't think I can...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh!
I didn't think you would just peek out!
No!
My son!
Oh my god, Broly!
Oh my god, it's in my head!
Oh my god, it's over.
It's so over.
It's over for him.
Not for me, not for me.
It's for him.
Okay, supply route.
Bookkeeping.
What did I get?
Oh, it's for the construction.
Large storage.
Oh, we need that.
Uh, storage expansion.
There's so many.
many quests.
Yeah, I can tell how this can be, like, super grindy.
How do I expand my storage?
This is just... Do it automatically?
Oh, wait, here it is.
Oh!
Okay, I gotta pick up my items first, guys.
Before anything else, we gotta pick up our items.
I claim all.
I don't even need a gun at this point.
I don't think I need a gun.
I have the battle axe.
I'm basically unstoppable until that one time I was stopped.
But, like, that doesn't count.
I'm practically unstoppable.
Except for that one time I was stopped.
But I'm practically unstoppable.
Alright.
Okay.
I got scared because that was how he killed me last time.
had to wait until he generously told me he was reloading thank god thank god he let me know okay i'm not gonna run i want to keep my sprint meet my sprint
okay that's faster all right after i grab this i'm gonna after grab all of this inventory and i'm leaving i'm booking it it was here it was here i have cover oh
god away from the reload of the time everything correctly i'm
trying to be like very cautious right now i'm so scared
the reload punish
please tell me he doesn't see me oh god i think if he shoots me one time i fucked okay i think for this guy definitely a shoot him from here jesus christ look at him oh god oh my god okay it's fine it's fine
okay he's reloading holy shit he doesn't even turn it to a He just turns into a goddamn suitcase.
Oh my god, it's that MFMF.
Oh my god, it's a good-ass gun.
Alright.
Only has, like, one mag, but it's a good-ass gun.
That's a fucking good gun.
I'm not gonna...
I'm gonna loot this real quick.
What?
Wow.
Did you hear that?
Oh my god, he can roll!
oh my god give me i was like what the was that sound bro was fucking it was a tank was a goddamn
tank okay wait wait maybe okay wait how dead am i if i run up and melee him like how fucked am i for doing that oh my god he's right here where the fuck is he oh
where is he i hear him he's so loud oh my god he's right behind me isn't he oh my god i'm so paranoid where i'm so paranoid where is he oh god he's just running around oh my god he's gonna
Oh my god.
He's right behind me.
he's right behind All right.
We're leaving we're leaving.
We've had her we don't we we tried we tried And that's all that matters.
We were so brave We were so brave
Bro, you are not him.
Return to Duck Cop.
Alright, let's...
I don't have eight...
I must have eight feathers now.
Yeah, I definitely do.
Because there is no way what do I get?
I get a totem?
What is that?
Is that it?
Oh, I got a ninja.
What offer does this give me?
I'll save up for that.
Wait, equip them.
Oh!
Oh, I'm slightly reduces distance.
Running sound range.
Oh, it gives me a...
Oh, it's like totems.
I'll get more.
Oh, that's cool.
What else do I get?
Agus?
Okay, we're replacing that.
That seems a lot better.
Oh, the 80 is just 10 pull.
Oh, it's gotcha.
Oh, okay.
Hello, I got your shit.
Oh, not that.
Okay, I need intermediate parts.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
We gotta upgrade.
Yeah, I can tell how this can get like...
Because it feels...
It definitely feels super grindy.
HB3 as your first pull is streamer luck.
Oh, is it like it's hard?
Yeah?
Like it's supposed to be hard or something?
Okay.
Uh, what ammo does it take?
Rusty bullet.
Okay, we don't need that then.
Let's put all of this away.
I will do one more run.
Gotta go to sleep, though.
Alright.
Is this, like, early access-ish, right?
Or is it, like, fully- I feel like...
I don't know, actually.
I don't know if this is supposed to be fully completed.
But, um, I hope they add more stuff.
to it no runs in the night you know what let's do our last run at night you're right it's one point oh it's full release okay definitely feels like um it can they can expand this so much more for sure i would like to have like a pub g-esque like of escape from dark duck off all right let's do night nike cues
Co-op would be really fun And then doing your Like going to other people's bases And stuff Alright I'm ready This is only First zone?
I thought that was the Entire map Oh my god
I didn't Realize I was like wow that's why I was like Oh this was here This is first I've been stuck in the zone for so long i didn't even realize i oh i don't oh night time is even spookier oh spooky scary skills get good oh no no no no no no no no no no i'm so catsy shit I actually can't see shit.
Okay, scary skeleton.
Oh my god, this is scary.
Who would have thought?
What the?
Oh my god!
Question mark, question mark, question!
What?
That's not a...
That's not a duck!
Alright, so...
I'm gonna hit the bed.
Alright, so now that we know not to head out at night time, what did we learn today, class?
What did I throw?
It was a fucking droid!
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, I think I...
Yeah, I don't think nighttime was it, guys.
I had a Oh my god, that's nearly a tire Why can't I bring this one home?
No, now?
Because I was like, what the fuck was that sound?
That sounded very Not duck-like
That didn't For some reason, that didn't sound like a duck What could that be?
Wham, whamam Wham I missed, but it doesn't matter because he was like, you missed.
I like how the duck was like, wait, I didn't expect you to miss.
I didn't have a plan B.
Boom.
Gee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whack, whack.
Alright, this will be my last run.
Oh.
Gotta loot this guy.
I'm gonna take his gun so I can sell it.
It's so strong.
It's so stupid that the axe is the strongest weapon right now.
In the first zone.
Oh yeah, no, it's so satisfying.
Let's see, where the fuck do I go?
How do I unlock the other?
Do I just go to North Mountain and it locks it?
I'm still trying to find a tire.
Just like...
Okay, I'm gonna go this way.
Oh.
There's some fighting going on.
Who is he fighting?
Oh, he's fighting a dog.
Oh, wait.
He lost to the dog.
He was fighting the dog.
Oh, I remember.
I couldn't go past it because there was a wall.
They literally put a wall.
There we go.
Oh my god, that's good.
We got the crafting material.
Yeah, how the fuck do I get past this wall?
That's why That's why I'm stuck in the zone You sure I've rolled Ducks can rolled Clanker is cat It's thinking of the super chat thing Oh the dynamite I have a dynamite It's in my warehouse I do have it Oh Get over here You made a mistake There you Oh He's like,
that's right.
You try to reload in front of me.
It's death time.
Oh, I never got in this way before.
Surprising with how small this area is, there's a lot of places I haven't gone.
I have one more inventory slot left.
That should be an important item to get.
All right, never mind.
All right, I think.
I think we can head home.
I mean, I got one crafting material, but yeah.
I think that's all right.
I'm definitely, like, not exploring efficiently.
I can feel it.
I feel like, oh, wait, battery.
Wait, I haven't seen a battery before.
Um, we'll put this.
We'll put this away.
I don't know.
I feel like, wait, he's red.
Oh, sh!
Oh!
It's the ravagers!
Oh, that's Where they are!
Hey, nice Okay, that's scared Shit, I'm going to use all my band-aids
Okay Actually, I feel like Where are the other ravagers?
Where the fuck are the- Oh, there he is.
Oh, no.
There we go.
Oh, so that's where we had to get these guys.
Nice.
that's actually convenient oh shit I'm so thirsty oh shit oh wait I'm oh my god I have bleach don't worry guys I almost just drank bleach don't worry do not drink the bleach down the hatch
oh I can open it from the set All right, shortcut time.
We actually have to leave.
Okay, we finished the request.
Yay!
You got a shortcut.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That was a strong-ass door.
What?
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I don't expect him to just fucking show up.
All right, let's go home.
I have so much ammo that I can just spray and pray.
Alright.
Yay, shortcut.
Got my axe ready.
What?
Whatchu.
Alright.
Oh yeah, I could.
It's alright.
We don't need it.
I wasn't going to give my dog cigarettes.
I feel like maybe I shouldn't.
I was going to give dad my cigarettes.
cigarettes.
I don't want him to know.
I think that was a good last run.
I got that.
And we also got the butcher knife too.
Span it pockets.
Use the skill enhancer.
Didn't I already do that?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That's like one of the first things full of love.
Yeah, I have a lot of money.
for that.
Kill any enemy.
Headshots required.
Bro, it's top down.
How the fuck?
How do I, like, even, like, isn't that already, like, a given?
Oh, nice, medic station.
Wait, we need that, actually.
Put it here.
Oh, nice, we have medic station now.
Finally.
Okay.
Alright, little supplies.
General medicine.
I feel like I have a lot of first aid kits, yeah.
That's good.
Yeah, do I just aim at them?
I was, like, thinking, like, isn't that a given?
I got a pen.
Alright.
What do I just give me?
Oh, wait!
I can finally...
Oh, my God.
I can finally do it.
Wait, how do I...
What?
I have blueprints Hello?
How come it doesn't?
Oh, wait, what the fuck is the?
Is it only for medicine?
Oh, it's for medicine blueprints.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I get it.
I was so confused.
I was like, huh?
I have blueprints right here.
Why won't you take it?
Oh, oh my god, I could have done this this entire time.
I didn't even realize.
And that is already registered.
Okay, I can sell that.
I can sell that.
I can finally sell some of my blueprints.
Oh my I can not... Oh, where is it that?
Nice.
I try to make weapons and now... Where else am I supposed to do it i don't understand this is an emergency is it not okay let's craft this oh this is like so deep there's like so much stuff you can do here wait actually we need that repair station there's is actually so like a lot more complicated and expected we're like i feel like they made this as a joke,
and the people were like, wait a minute, this is pretty good.
And they're like, wait a minute, wait, we got some, wait, we're cooking right now.
I have a lot of glutes.
This feels like it was made as a joke, but then they were like, oh, wait, wait, I think we got something.
I like how my storage is just jazz.
Alright, we gotta call it here.
I feel like I could, I definitely can see how this game was is super addicting and how it sold a million copies because of how much you can do in this game because like i feel like i've only just scratched the surface of what escape from duck cough has to offer but and like this is my first time playing like uh like i've never played dark off before but i can understand like the grind of this game yeah yeah especially though and there's no hackers around you know and you don't have to be like super fucking paranoid about a sniper 500 miles away from you like i think i definitely the only issue is like i don't know where items spawn i think that's like my only issue so like i i feel like i'm collecting a lot of junk because i don't know where to loot like yeah yeah no i've been i was like checking this game out and i saw like it's very popular nation i saw like a lot of people were streaming it um in like especially in japan i saw a lot of like japanese streamers uh playing escape from
duck off and um i could see like why like because this gives like because like like you know it gives the tarcoff itch and stuff um um but yeah for this this sold a million copies so i was like really curious about it and i saw that um i saw that like you know like i was i was looking at steam i was like what like i thought it was just a joke game but then like everyone was like this is the best extraction shooter ever made and i was like That's a crazy statement because a lot of extraction shooters have been made.
I don't know if you guys know that, but there was a lot of extraction shooters.
So I was like very curious.
But anyway, I'm going to call it here.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
It was really nice exploring, escape from Duck Calf.
I had fun time checking it out.
I don't know if I'll stream more of it.
I feel like it's a game I definitely might play off stream.
But I don't know if I'll stream more of it on stream.
Because I feel like it's just more like a grindy thing.
If I'm like bored, I just be like, alright, time to go in and go swish swish.
But I hope you guys have fun watching.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around.
blood flowing and if you except for me head to bed because you deserve it i'm gonna call here i feel my voice feeling a little strained today so i'm gonna go take a break and like um rest my voice today um so yeah i'm gonna head out maybe take a little nap i've been i think like i haven't been napping too much though i i thought i fixed my sleep schedule today because um i actually woke up at uh actually went to bed at a decent time and also uh woke up at a decent time but i feel so tired i don't know why i don't know i feel like i want i mean it's 8 p.m though i feel like i shouldn't take a nap i feel like i'm gonna mess up my sleep schedule again um because i'm gonna take a nap and i'll wake up at some god awful time so yeah it's it's never fixed that's the
but we'll see we'll see how i feel i don't know maybe maybe i'll like stay up for a little bit and then and then uh stay up for a little bit and then go to bed a real time hey guys wait did i already say okay i'll say again if i didn't as long as everybody stay hydrated pause check get a move around to get that blood flowing and if you step for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everyone uh bye guys bye